>> WE WOULD EXPECT THIS AS A
LAST TRANCHE BUT OBVIOUSLY WE
CAN RECONSIDER THAT.
THIS IS A LOT OF MONEY GOING
OUT, OVER $600 BILLION PUTTING
INTO SMALL BUSINESSES WHICH ARE
THE BACKBONE OF THE ECONOMY, 50%
OF THE PRIVATE PAYROLL.
THAT’S UP TO TRILLION DOLLAR
WEIGHT AID PACKAGE.
LISTEN TO NANCY PELOSI’S
REACTION TO THIS.
>> TWO WEEKS AGO, HE CAME TO THE
FLOOR, AND HE SAID THIS IS ALL
THEY ARE DOING.
THE DEMOCRATS WERE REUNITED,
HOUSE AND SENATE, THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS WENT TO THE FLOOR AND
SAID IT, NO, WE HAVE A BETTER
IDEA.
>> SO THAT WAS THEM EARLIER
TODAY, AND THEY SAID GOOD
AFTERNOON TO YOU AND A VERY
EMPTY WASHINGTON, D.C.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
>> GLAD TO BE WITH YOU.
I THINK, WE ARE TRYING TO GET
REALLY FOR THE SMALL BUSINESS
PACKAGE.
BUT IT WAS IN FACT DELAYED BY
DEMOCRATIC MANEUVERS.
AND WE PUT $310 BILLION IN TWO
REPLENISH THE PROGRAM FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES WHICH RAN OUT OF
MONEY 12 DAYS AGO.
WE ALSO ADDED $75 BILLION FOR
HOSPITALS AND WE KNOW THEY ARE
STRUGGLING.
PROBABLY EVEN MORE IMPORTANT TO
THE OUTCOME OF $25 BILLION FOR
TESTING.
WE HAVE REALLY DEVELOPED KIND OF
A MANHATTAN PROJECT APPROACH TO
TESTING BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
EVEN WHEN THE GOVERNORS BEGIN TO
OPEN UP THE ECONOMY, AS IN MY
VIEW THEY SHOULD BEGIN TO DO,
AND WHEN HOSPITALS ARE ALLOWED
ONCE AGAIN TO DO ELECTIVE
SURGERY WHICH IS THE ONLY PLACE
THEY MAKE ANY MONEY, WE CAN
BEGIN TO GET OUT OF THIS MALAISE
BY BRINGING THE ECONOMY BACK TO
LIFE.
SPIVEY ONE WE WILL ASK ABOUT
THAT IN A MOMENT, BUT THAT’S
WHAT SHE SAID, SHE MADE THE BILL
BETTER BECAUSE THE TESTING ON
THE BILLIONS THAT ARE NO
AVAILABLE FOR HOSPITALS.
THAT’S A POINT SHE WAS MAKING.
AND WE ARE ALL INTERESTED IN
THAT AND NONE OF THAT WAS IN
CONTENTION.
WHAT THEY REALLY WANTED TO DO
WAS TO PASS LEGISLATION TO SEND
MONEY TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
WHAT I SAID WAS WE ARE NOT GOING
TO DO THAT, WE WILL WAIT AND
TAKE A PAUSE, AND WE WILL ASSESS
THE FUTURE POTENTIAL DAMAGE TO
THE COUNTRY BY ADDING
$2.7 TRILLION TO THE NATIONAL
DEBT.
THE NEXT TIME WE CONSIDER, SHALL
I SAY, PHASE FOUR, ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE ARE BACK,
WHICH WOULD BE THE EARLIEST
MAY 4TH.
WE ARE NOT INTERESTED IN IN
REVENUE FOR STATE GOVERNMENTS,
WE ARE NOT INTERESTED IN SOLVING
THEIR PENSION PROBLEMS AND ALL
THESE OTHER THINGS THAT THEY
WOULD LIKE FOR US TO FINANCE.
>> TO THAT POINT,
MAYOR BILL de BLASIO SAID HE
WANTS WASHINGTON TO PROVIDE
$7.4 BILLION TO HELP NEW YORK.
THAT’S JUST THE CITY.
ARE YOU SAYING TODAY THAT WILL
NOT HAPPY THAT THAT WILL HAPPEN?
>> WHAT I’M SAYING IS, WE WILL
TAKE A PAUSE HERE AT LEAST UNTIL
MAY THE 4TH WHICH IS THE TIME
THEY WILL HAVE EVERYONE BACK IN
THE SENATE, AND CLEARLY BEFORE
WE PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND MAKE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE NO REVENUE
LOSSES.
AND MAKE CERTAIN THAT IF WE
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE
FOR STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
IT’S ONLY FOR CORONAVIRUS
RELATED AND THEY AREN’T TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THIS PANDEMIC,
SOLVING PROBLEMS WITH THEMSELVES
AND BAD DECISIONS IN THE PAST.
DO YOU SEE THE SENATE COMING
BACK TO WORK ON THE 4TH OF MAY?
>> THAT’S THE CURRENT PLAN.
>> Bill: SO HOW DO YOU SEE OR
WHAT TO FORECAST WHAT COULD BE
IN THE NEXT BILL, OR THE NEXT
TRANCHE OF HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS?
>> OF THE FIRST THING IS TO
DECIDE WHETHER THERE NEEDS TO BE
ANOTHER TRANCHE.
THE ULTIMATE SOLUTION TO THIS IS
TO GET THE ECONOMY BACK UP AND
RUNNING.
FOR EXAMPLE, IS ALREADY DOING IT
TO MIX UP THE DIRECTIONS, AND
THE SOLUTION TO THE HOSPITAL
PROBLEM IS ELECTIVE SURGERY
WHICH IS THE ONLY PLACE THEY ARE
MAKING ANY MONEY, THAT’S A STATE
DECISION.
SO ALL OF US WILL BE ENCOURAGING
OUR STATES TO BEGIN TO MOVE IN
THE DIRECTION OF GETTING BACK TO
NORMAL, BEARING IN MIND OF THE
ADVICE OF DR. FAUCI AND
DR. BIRX.
SOCIAL DISTANCING, THE
DESTIGMATIZATION OF WEARING A
MASK, NO ONE SHOULD BE
EMBARRASSED TO WEAR A MASK, AND
LESS IS BACK IN AND SOLVE THE
PROBLEM BY GETTING GROWTH BACK
IN OUR ECONOMY.
>> Bill: ONE LAST THING.
AND WHAT WORD WOULD YOU USE TO
DESCRIBE THAT?
HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE WHAT THE
EFFORTS HAVE DONE SO FAR.
OFF OF CAPITOL HILL?
>> I’VE TRIED TO DEAL WITH A
DISASTER BUT ANYTIME YOU THROW
$2.7 TRILLION OUT OVER A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME, AND THERE WERE
MISTAKES MADE.
THAT’S THE IMPACT ON THE COUNTRY
COUNTRY, ALL OF THIS COUNTRY
NEEDS TO BE CONSIDERED IN A MORE
THOUGHTFUL AND MORE MEASURED WAY